[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING - PETER GABRIEL,
"DOWNSIDE-UP"]
[APPLAUSE]
PETER GABRIEL: Hi there.
INTERVIEWER: Peter
Gabriel, Google.
Google, Peter Gabriel.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
INTERVIEWER: So this is another
Talks at Google event
from Mountain View, and we're
very, very pleased to welcome
musician, artist, and activist
Peter Gabriel here today.
We are going to have a great
chance to ask some questions
about the current tour and the
25th anniversary of "So,"
which is going to be released,
actually, at the end of
October, on October 22.
And we'll also some chance for
the audience to ask some
questions as well.
So why don't we get started?
You're here on tour.
You're kind of in the
middle of the tour.
And what was the story
behind the tour?
How did it come to be?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, there
were a number of things.
I mean, I've never really done
a retro tour before and was
pretty resistant.
I know Robert Plant quite well,
and we were sort of
chiding each other on who was
going to succumb to the big
money first.
And anyway, I went to see the
Beach Boys do "Pet Sounds,"
which I always used to love.
And that convinced me that to
see one of the records that
you enjoy from start to finish
was actually a good thing.
And that coincided with some
nice offers, so that was an
easy decision.
And I'm actually going to take
a sabbatical year this year
with my family.
We've got a teacher coming
out with us.
And so it helps underwrite that
sabbatical year as well.
So there were a number
of reasons.
But I decided to bring back
the band that originally
toured that record, and
so that's been fun.
And we're actually having
a great time.
We do the evening
in three parts.
So the first part is based on
the idea that the process is
often as interesting, if not
more interesting, than the
final product.
So we start off with an
unfinished song, and then we
do sort of rehearsal mode with
the house lights on.
That's the starter.
Then the main course is a few
songs, more electronic or
electric versions of things.
And then the last chunk, if you
can get through all that,
you get your dessert, which
is the "So" album.
So that's how it works.
INTERVIEWER: And specifically
about the "So" album, so
you're playing--
the actual tour is called
Back to Front.
And that seems to be some of the
format you just discussed.
But playing "So," the track
order that you have now, that
wasn't the original track
order, correct?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, this is an
interesting diversion about
technology.
Because although I'm a big fan
of vinyl, I was also a great
fan of the digital world because
suddenly, we could get
more dynamics in the music.
And there were restrictions
in the vinyl world.
For example, the track "In Your
Eyes," I always wanted to
go at the end of the record,
but it has a
good bass line there.
To get a fat bass line on a full
vinyl record, you can't
put it near the end.
You have to have it nearer the
beginning, so it went on the
start of side two, just because
there wasn't enough
room for the needle to vibrate
as it got close to the center.
So then, when CDs came along, I
was able to take that track
and put it back on
the end where it
always should have been.
INTERVIEWER: And on this release
that's coming up,
there's a couple variations,
as I understand it.
There's the CD itself.
You're re-releasing and you've
remastered that.
And that's a third time you've
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah, as long
as people keep buying it,
we'll remaster it.
INTERVIEWER: And then there's
actually going to be a
comprehensive box set that's
got both CDs, some material
that hasn't been released yet,
and also a DVD with some
concert footage.
Have you been just
sitting on this?
This has been in the stores?
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
We'll throw any old
shit in there.
INTERVIEWER: Hey, it
was old, get it in?
PETER GABRIEL: No, but there
were a couple of things that,
yeah, we were waiting
for the right day.
And the right day, you know, you
always get more interested
in the latest thing.
So we'd sort of forgotten
about it.
But also, we'd shot the film--
filmed the show 25,
26 years ago.
And Scorsese had been producing,
and he'd got this
wonderful cinematographer
doing it.
And we hadn't realized
quite what we had.
So we went back to the film--
I mean, tons of film cans
that had to be carefully
resurrected.
And then we took all the data
of the film and have a much
better resolution version of
that concept than we had done
previously.
INTERVIEWER: And the actual
production of "So," and then
also some of the videos and
documenting that, over what
time period did that
actually happen?
From when you thought about
the album that you did
originally to actually getting
it out the door?
PETER GABRIEL: Sorry,
this latest thing?
Or the original one.
INTERVIEWER: The original one.
PETER GABRIEL: I think that
just sort of happened as
things came up.
There wasn't really a brilliant
master plan.
It was when we finish
this, then what else
do we need to do?
And we try and film things.
I mean, again, if you have the
opportunity to have two gigs
in the same place, then it makes
filming a lot easier,
because you can do the set-up,
and all the mistakes you make
on first day, you can try
and sort out on the
second day of it.
And we did that in
Greece as well.
INTERVIEWER: So when you're
approaching songwriting, or
maybe at the time when you were
approaching songwriting
with regards to "So," did you
have a list of songs and then
say, OK, right, I'm going to
select these musicians to
start working with?
Or were you writing and
recording at the same time?
PETER GABRIEL: I'm always
writing lyrics until the day
it's released, really.
But I'm slow with those.
But yeah, there was
a few ideas.
In fact, I'd forgotten this,
but Manu and Tony said that
"Sledgehammer" was
an afterthought.
There was a taxi waiting to take
Manu back to Paris and we
had an hour left, and I think I
said, I've got this new idea
that maybe we could just
put a demo down on.
And that was it.
I mean, we carried on working on
it, because it felt great.
But it was quite an
afterthought.
INTERVIEWER: And then
"Sledgehammer" also took on a
life of its own when it came to
the video, which you worked
with Aardman on, and others.
And my son, straightaway,
he's like, the chickens.
That looks just like "Wallace
and Gromit."
PETER GABRIEL: The chickens.
Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: How did
that come to be?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, actually,
it was-- yeah, the man who did
the chickens was the man who
created "Wallace and Gromit."
And I was working with this
brilliant director, Stephen R.
Johnson, and he brought in the
Quay brothers, who have
fantastic, sort of dark, East
European-looking animation.
And I saw they've now got a big
thing at MoMA in New York.
And I brought in Aardman
Animation, who were from down
the road in Bristol.
Stephen and I had a couple of
weeks just bashing through
ideas, and then we brought
in the others.
And it was a really exciting,
creative brainstorming.
And I mean, that's always been
one of the things I most enjoy
about what I do, is working
with people from different
backgrounds, often smarter than
I am, and just cooking
something up.
So it was a great experience,
but quite painful, too,
because we did everything
in the old-fashioned
way, frame by frame.
So when you see a sky moving
across my face, that is being
painted frame by frame, and
the skin gets very raw.
And when you're under glass with
a lot of raw fish on day
one, that's fine.
But day two, it's--
[LAUGHTER]
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
At least you put the
blame on the fish.
INTERVIEWER: And that video,
I think, is actually the
most-played video ever on MTV.
I mean, granted they don't
play quite as many videos
these days.
But still--
[LAUGHTER]
PETER GABRIEL: Do
they play any?
Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: That's a huge
accomplishment, and I think
that it also--
I mean, having been relatively
young at that age, it was so
different than most anything
that was out there.
And it really set a standard
for also an experience that
was getting you into the mind
of the writer and the artist
in a different way, I think,
of seeing an entertainment
value that wasn't just for the
sake of entertainment but also
telling a story.
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah, I think--
I mean, what was great about
videos then was that there
were people that wanted to watch
them, and there was a
budget, and there
were no rules.
So you could do what the hell
you wanted, and there was no
one there to say, no, this
is the way we do it.
INTERVIEWER: And when
you approach--
kind of back to songwriting,
I want to just ask.
I think Mike Rutherford maybe
made the comment once that
you're a frustrated
drummer over time.
And you started as a
drummer in school.
Do you think you think
more rhythmically
originally about a song?
Or do you think more
melodically?
PETER GABRIEL: I think both.
I mean, there are some
things which are
just based on melody.
But groove is what drove
me into music.
I thought drummers, they seem
to be in command of this
really loud thing.
And it looks like
a lot of fun.
And that's what I
wanted to be.
I was very enthusiastic.
Not very good.
And it was fine in the early
days of Genesis, because we
had guys who weren't--
they were good, solid drummers,
but they weren't
that creative.
And then when we got Phil,
unfortunately, he was a way
better drummer than I was.
But I used to still have some
bits of my drum kit on stage,
and I would find my bass
drum full of carpet.
And gradually, these things
were getting reduced.
So there was a subtle way of
saying that maybe I wasn't the
best timekeeper.
However, I worked also--
I mean, being a major drum fan,
I worked with some of the
best drummers in the
world, I think.
And one of those is Stewart
Copeland, who is also a lousy
timekeeper.
But he's--
INTERVIEWER: Just don't tell
that to Stewart Copeland.
PETER GABRIEL: No,
I've told him.
He'll say it himself,
because he races.
But by the energy he puts into
his drumming and the attack on
it is fantastic.
And he does that brilliantly.
INTERVIEWER: And on the album,
he played hi-hat on--
PETER GABRIEL: Well,
this is the thing.
I had so many wonderful drummers
I could cut out bits
and pieces and get a bit of
hi-hat from Stewart, a kick
from Manu, and I mean, whatever
it was, it was just--
but I'm a bit obsessive, as
you might guess from this.
You know, the groove
has to be right.
And I think we worked quite hard
trying to find grooves
that aren't the regular ones
you're hearing on the radio.
INTERVIEWER: And I think with
having this band back on stage
together, is there some kind
of moments where you look
around and it's deja vu?
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
And we all look exactly the same
as we did 25 years ago.
Well actually, a couple
of the guys do.
I wish I could say that.
But it's a bit like family
get-togethers, because you end
up with the same bunch of folk
doing exactly the same thing
that you always did, with all
the pleasures and problems
that went along the
first time.
So it feels very familiar.
But I'm enjoying it a lot.
INTERVIEWER: And as far as the
way in which the songs of
evolve when you're on tour,
do you try out--
there's that section that's
defined as, let's play with
these more.
But you also come back
and rearrange the
songs a little bit.
Are they the same songs that you
start out at the beginning
of the tour when you
wind up at the end?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, we try and
get them right, you know?
So we are--
I mean, we're tweaking.
Every sound check, we try and
find a few of the weaknesses
and nail them.
And we never used to play all
those tracks together, partly
because two of them were
a bitch to get right.
And we couldn't get
them working.
So I think we're closing
in on them, anyway.
But yeah, you do want
to keep changing it.
However, I keep forgetting--
because we did start off
rehearsing some other
stuff as well.
But now, once we've got things
beginning to feel like a real
show and working properly, then
when you do change the
numbers over, then it means also
you've got to reprogram
the lights and all that stuff.
So I think we will be doing
that and getting some
flexibility, but gently.
INTERVIEWER: And in
a tour like this--
I know that you've always put
a lot of energy and time to
make a concert just a full
experience, not just, OK, now
here's some nice lights and here
are the songs, hopefully
played the best they can be.
But also the experience of
the songs, in a way.
How much time does go into
actually prepping
for a tour like this?
PETER GABRIEL: Well,
there's a fair bit.
I mean, I've got some
very smart people.
And in fact, there was an idea,
originally 25, 26 years
ago, when I was just doing
videos, and I saw the cameras
on these booms that were being
manually operated.
And I thought the way they
moved was really cool.
So we replaced the cameras
with lights.
And now we've got lights
with little
cameras on them as well.
But they're still manually
operated.
And I'm working on another show
after this, which will be
more robotic, I think.
But this one, I'm really
enjoying the sort of manual
element, which is, I think--
it feels quite futuristic and
retro simultaneously.
INTERVIEWER: And speaking of
robots, you've always been, I
guess what in Silicon Valley
speak, would be an early
adopter of technology, and
released some CD-ROMs, and
you've been using, back to
drums, the first kind of
gated, or largely used
gated drum sounds,
and things like that.
Have you just always had a
fascination with technology?
Or how do you use it to
stimulate creativity?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, my dad was
an inventor, an electrical
engineer, and designed, with
an Italian, a system--
it was a TV system called
Dial-a-Program.
But in a way, it was home
shopping, electronic
democracy, entertainment on
demand, but it was 1971 and
accessed through the rotary
dial of a telephone.
So he, I think, then tried
to sell it, and it was
a little too early.
But I saw him passionate
about what technology
could do for people.
And so I think that although I
don't have his skills, I have
his enthusiasm.
So I still love to get involved
with all sorts of
techie things.
INTERVIEWER: And I think I'll
open up for questions in a
sec, if people want
to line up.
But around selecting musicians,
because you have
worked with so many, what's the
process whereby you kind
of discover or like
to collaborate?
Because spoiled for choice, you
could bring in all these
different folks as you develop
new music or go back
to visit old ones.
It's probably tough to select.
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah,
it's difficult.
I mean, I think I like to have
a core, a family around me,
because there's a shorthand.
It's just more efficient.
And if you want to get ideas,
and people know what it is you
like and what works and
what doesn't work,
I think it's speed.
I think the great giants of the
creative process that are
hardly ever acknowledged, which
I'm sure applies in your
world, are boredom
and fatigue.
And they hover over
everything.
And as soon as you get tired or
bored, the thing is dead.
So it's trying to keep things
sparkly and crackling long
enough to support life
on their own.
And that's, I think, best
achieved in my case with some
home team and some new,
exciting, inspiring guests.
INTERVIEWER: So as far as
becoming more efficient and
creative, do you think you've
managed that over time?
PETER GABRIEL: I'm not sure.
I'm still terrible at getting
lyrics finished.
I feel I can come up with some
musical ideas I'm happy with
fairly quickly.
But lyrics, I have to go off,
isolate myself from my family.
And I have a theory, which
probably-- a lot of smart
people here.
Someone could tell me if there's
any substance in it.
But peripheral visual
stimulation.
In other words, if I
get on a train--
and I know a lot of other
creative folk who get a lot
more ideas on a train than they
do sitting at a desk.
And I think that when you're in
a train or in a car, you've
got stuff coming past you.
And in the old days, when we
were either chasing or being
chased, and there were a lot of
important things dependent
on it, like whether we survived
to tomorrow, the body
had some mechanism for
accelerating and pumping
adrenaline around when you get
this peripheral visual
acceleration or speed.
So that's what I do
when I get stuck.
I get on a train.
And I've suggested that to quite
a few other folk who've
had some success with it.
So anyway, that's my
offering for today.
And we do have a sponsorship
from a train company.
INTERVIEWER: I think
Caltrain's about
to get a lot busier.
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I was lucky enough
to see your tour in
1986 when you did this
album the first time.
Greatest tour of
my ever life--
PETER GABRIEL: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Show of my life,
I've ever seen.
Sorry, I'm a little nervous.
And I was really excited when
you mentioned the lights on
the jib arm.
That's like a visual memory that
stuck with me since then.
PETER GABRIEL: Great.
Well, we don't have--
I mean, we have one or two
overhead lights, but the
normal sort of proscenium arch
and so on, we've thrown away.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to ask
a couple of quick questions
about other things you might
have considered bringing back
to use again.
The first-- and I'm probably
going to say his name wrong,
but when I saw you, the opening
act was Youssou
N'Dour, who sang on "In Your
Eyes." And he, of course, came
out and sang with you.
Were you able to get him
to come out and tour
with you this time?
PETER GABRIEL: Sadly, he was--
they actually created a new
law in Senegal to stop him
becoming president.
And he's now minister of
culture, because he's
like god out there.
And so he's not really doing
much music at the moment.
Besides which, he's a great and
celebrated artist in his
own right now, so the idea of
back-up on my tour, I'm sure--
[LAUGHTER]
PETER GABRIEL: But you know,
he's godfather to my son, and
I am to one of his, so we're
still very good friends.
But he's an amazing artist.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And the other is a little bit
more on the technology side,
recreating the sounds.
For example, did you have to
dig out your old Fairlight,
and do the floppy disks
still work?
Or how do you do that to
recreate all those old sounds.
PETER GABRIEL: I think
actually archiving--
yeah.
Your history is your future.
Because we were talking with
some of the Pixar folk, and
they were saying that they
couldn't play back some of the
files from the original
"Toy Story."
And it's a real issue, I think,
that there's some
consciousness of how we can
hold stuff in [INAUDIBLE].
I think they're taking digital
stuff and putting it on film,
so it's all back to front.
And I mean, maybe some people
here have solved this, but I
think it's an issue that
needs careful thought.
We did take some
of the sounds.
But yeah, some of the floppies
weren't working, and we had
trouble looking for
DAT players.
But yeah, there are one or two
people who've been smart
enough to try and hold onto bits
of historical technology
and try and keep it working so
that desperate people like
myself can be rescued.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Mr. Gabriel.
I'm a lifelong fan.
And I hope you never stop making
music, and I hope you
always sing "Wallflower" in
every concert you do.
PETER GABRIEL: Oh, thank you.
I'm not playing it
tonight, but.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Had to try.
My question is a little
bit weird.
In "Solsbury Hill," the last
verse is very, you saying
you're going to go home, and
that kind of closes the story
nicely and wraps up the song.
PETER GABRIEL: Sorry, which?
AUDIENCE: "Solsbury."
PETER GABRIEL: "Solsbury,"
right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so I'm wondering,
I'm curious why
when you sing it live sometimes,
oftentimes I've
heard you sing it, and the last
verse, you tend to sing
the original first part of
the verse, you know--
I'm just so nervous.
I'm going to forget it.
PETER GABRIEL: OK.
AUDIENCE: But I'm just
wondering if it's--
PETER GABRIEL: Is this,
I screw up the lyrics?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Why do you screw up
the last verse of "Solsbury
Hill?"
PETER GABRIEL: OK.
It's because I screw up lyrics
on a regular basis.
And I used to just read the
lips of the front row.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER GABRIEL: Which was fine
when they'd learned the
English version.
And now, of course, we have
prompting screens which are
for those senior moments.
AUDIENCE: That was it.
Thank you very much.
PETER GABRIEL: Thank you.
Of course, you've got to
be able to read them.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Peter, I'm
a huge lifetime fan.
All throughout my college days,
I had a huge poster of
you on my wall.
PETER GABRIEL: We were
just good friends.
AUDIENCE: So it's nice
to see you live.
I also attended the '86 concert
and it was the best
concert of my life also.
And I remember you walking
in that circular wheel.
PETER GABRIEL: The hamster
cage, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And just wondering
if there's going to be any
more things like that
at today's concert.
PETER GABRIEL: It's pretty
simple, and it's just really
these old lights on the booms.
This one was more about the
music and less about the
production.
The next one I'm planning, it's
the other way around.
But right now, that's
the focus.
AUDIENCE: And the other question
I had was a while
back, Salman Ahmad from Junoon,
he was here at Google,
and he mentioned that you were
going to be doing a recording
together and doing maybe
some concerts.
Is that in the plans?
PETER GABRIEL: He sent me some
stuff, which I'm still hoping
that we can work on with
some Qawwali things.
Because he was doing a fantastic
job singing with
some of the Qawwali stuff.
And so I'm still hoping
something
will happen with that.
With our record company, because
of the collapse of the
record business, we have to
get a sign-in from various
partners before we can proceed,
and we haven't had
that as yet.
But I'm still hoping that we may
be able to get something
going there.
He's an interesting musician.
AUDIENCE: And the last question
I have is, will you
be doing any more world music
concerts and putting on--
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah,
we still--
we have our world music
festival, WOMAD.
And that has just had its
30th anniversary.
And it's done well, and we've
had it in 80 countries now.
And we'd like to try bringing
it back over here.
We were in--
I forget, I think '92--
Golden Gate Parkway, and then
we had a sort of future zone
area, which was a
techie thing.
Because I'm still in love with
the idea of science and
technology and handmade and
traditional culture.
And I hope we'll be able to
reintroduce that part of it
into the WOMAD festival.
But it's still something that
we're trying to evolve.
AUDIENCE: And I just wanted to
let you know that one of my
favorite songs from you that
puts shudders through me is a
that song called "Biko."
PETER GABRIEL: Oh,
right, yeah.
Well, we'll be finishing
tonight with it.
AUDIENCE: Mr. Gabriel, it is
an honor to have you here.
PETER GABRIEL: Thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: So we wondered--
today that cell phones and
cameras are everywhere.
We wondered if there has
been any follow-up
on the WITNESS project?
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
And I think we've had some help
from google.org, and also
with the YouTube folk,
on getting a
human rights channel.
Because before, the problem was,
I mean, we tried to do
our own human rights
destination
thing called The Hub.
And the problem was that it was
doing its job well, which
was basically to provide more
security, anonymity, and
context around any bit
of video, but we
didn't have the eyeballs.
And so YouTube clearly has lots
of eyeballs, so along
with Storyful, we're now
working on that.
And I think we're just
beginning to see the
transformation that the
mobile phone is going
to have in our world.
And it's absolutely huge.
I'm really excited.
I mean, you see what's happening
in the Middle East
or any area of protest, that
the young people protesting
don't feel isolated in a way
that they did before.
National sovereignty, borders,
were very effective in the
past whenever those in power
wanted to shut down protest.
And it doesn't work
in the same way.
I mean, clearly technology can
be used for good or for bad.
And it's a cat-and-mouse game,
and at the same time, in
providing for activism, for
health care, for education.
And I mean, I got suckered
into a thing--
we have this Elders project,
which is former statesmen.
In fact, I'll just lay
out the pitch.
Because the way I see it, if you
have anything bad going on
in the world and then you can
map it, in the way that
Ushahidi has done, for instance,
that it will never
be forgotten.
And then you can go and sort
of zoom into that and hear
personal stories and the voices
of those affected.
So it's not being interpreted
by the outside, but they're
telling their own stories.
And that's where YouTube Witness
and various others,
Global Voices, all come in.
Then you have sort of
campaign-building, and a
viral, is I think, probably the
most effective at that.
If there are 15 million now,
there could be 150 million, or
numbers that politicians
can no longer ignore.
And then the Elders, where
you can have high-level
interventions, so you go
straight to parliament, or
presidents, or whoever it is,
but connected to what's
happening on the ground.
Then you start to see this whole
other infrastructure
forming that is based around the
mobile phone that I really
think can transform the world.
And just from the health care
side, we're seeing some of
these, like the Tricorder Prize,
a where I think 20
parameters--
the tricorder, for those who
didn't watch "Star Trek," was
the device that you could wave
over someone and it would give
you everything that was good and
bad about what was going
on in their body.
And we are going to be
completely unable to provide
high-tech health care
for the world,
except through the mobile.
And there are all these
wonderful things coming along.
But as a scanner, I think the
Tricorder Prize is going to go
within the next 18 months, two
years, and that can read these
parameters better.
I mean, we have things
that already--
I saw this scanner that went
into the blood, looked at the
cartinoids, gave you reading.
So it could tell you,
you know, two
doughnuts in, you're [WHISTLE].
Three days of healthy
eating, and you're
back up to your level.
But suddenly, you've then got
competitive feedback and group
psychology on keeping us well.
And anyway, I go on for a long
time on this stuff because I
am so excited by it.
And I know all of you guys are
working on these things.
And I think it's completely up
to us, whether it's used
positively or negatively.
While I'm on one, data I think
is going to be a huge area.
And I know this is potentially
contentious, but I think we
have, or should have, legal
right to own or co-own any
data that we generate
in a digital world.
And that's something that I
hope the Elders will be
campaigning for along with
a lot of other people.
Because clearly, that has
real commercial value.
But when we are allowed to touch
and own or co-own that,
I think that will be a sort of
self-regulating mechanism
which is fundamental
to the evolution
of the digital world.
INTERVIEWER: And the Elders,
just for context, is a group
of senior leaders
and luminaries--
Jimmy Carter, Desmond Tutu--
PETER GABRIEL: Kofi Annan, Mary
Robinson, Ela Bhatt--
I mean, they're extraordinary
people.
And it was the idea of just
trying to get a group of--
there's 10 of them at the
moment, but the idea is there
should be 12--
we got Mandela to found
it originally.
And they can make
interventions.
But I think our dream,
or my dream--
I think some of the Elders'
dream, too-- is that when that
then can be connected to these
movements that grow up from
the ground, that can give voice
to the voiceless, et
cetera, that it can be part of a
new mechanism for balancing.
AUDIENCE: And I have a--
PETER GABRIEL: Sorry,
yeah, you didn't
expect all that shit.
AUDIENCE: I have a message from
a very good, dear friend
of mine who actually introduced
me to your music,
that he misses the transparent
bulls and feathers.
PETER GABRIEL: The feathers?
I don't remember the feathers.
But the transparent bulls--
well, I won't take my
trousers off now.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Mr. Gabriel.
PETER GABRIEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: This is the coolest
thing ever, incidentally,
talking to you like this.
PETER GABRIEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Me my friends went
to your '86 concert.
We're all going again tonight.
It'll be a lot of fun.
You talked earlier about
revisiting old stuff.
Any chance we'll hear
from Rael again?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, there was
an illustrator I met in
Chicago who's sort of working on
something-- and one or two
people ask about film stuff.
And I think if some serious
steam got underway with "Lamb"
as a film project, then I
think that might sort of
regurgitate some of
the rest of it.
AUDIENCE: Because you have to
know that that was totally
groundbreaking.
It's one of my favorite pieces
of music of all time.
PETER GABRIEL: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for doing this.
PETER GABRIEL: OK.
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big fan.
PETER GABRIEL: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Particularly going
back to Genesis, "Selling
England by the Pound,"
one of my favorite
albums of all time.
My question, many, many years
ago, I guess maybe around the
time of "So," I had a friend who
was writing music, and he
was a big fan of
yours as well.
And he was all, Peter Gabriel's
playing in town.
Think I'm going to go to the
concert and see if I can catch
him afterwards and shoot him a
tape, and maybe he'll hear it
and really like it.
And maybe we'll work together.
And I'm all, uh, yeah, I'm not
sure that's going to happen.
But--
INTERVIEWER: We'll take
the tape right now--
AUDIENCE: I wondered if--
I wondered, did you
get the tape?
And if so, what did
you think of it?
PETER GABRIEL: Well--
AUDIENCE: Seriously,
though, I mean--
PETER GABRIEL: Well, the entire
"So" album was actually
a ripoff of that tape.
AUDIENCE: But it's always
made me very curious.
You must get inundated with
this kind of stuff.
And I'm curious how much you
get, what you do with it, how
you deal with it, and if
anything interesting has ever
come out of these
kind of things.
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah, we still
do get a lot of stuff.
I used to worry a lot about
it, and I'm afraid I
don't so much now.
And there's a lot more than we
could ever listen to, so we've
got our record company to.
So they do some listening.
And we have, I think
Hukwe Zawose was--
has sadly passed, but he's
an amazing singer.
I think that fell through the
letterbox at one point.
So some things have just come
in out of the blue, but it's
more often through
personal contact.
INTERVIEWER: And I have to
confess, Jerry Marotta, who
played on "So," drums as
well, I met once--
I used to play in a band.
I was kind of a drummer, more
of a controlled flailer.
But I actually gave
him a tape.
PETER GABRIEL: Oh, you did?
INTERVIEWER: And so I'd also
like to have some credit.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Unfortunately, I wasn't alive
for the '86 show.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER GABRIEL: I was
going to say--
INTERVIEWER: We won't hold
that against you.
PETER GABRIEL: I was going to
say, that makes two of us.
AUDIENCE: Anyways, I really
enjoy Real World Records and
the remix contest you did.
And your CD is obviously
amazing.
I'm just curious what advice
you'd give to young producers
and mixing engineers who are
trying to make it in today's
world, where it seems like
credits aren't really a thing
in the digital world.
Like you download an MP3, and
you can't look at a liner
note, right?
PETER GABRIEL: Right.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
feel about that?
And are you behind, like, the
Grammy petition that's
currently going on to get
these music services to
include liner notes,
et cetera?
PETER GABRIEL: I didn't actually
know about it, but I
think I would be, because I
think people work their asses
off sometimes.
And there should be a way that
you can drill down and find
out everything about anything.
So I would support that.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Peter, thanks
for coming to Google.
PETER GABRIEL: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: You discovered a lot
of raw talent, music talent,
like Nusrat, from the
subcontinent.
I wanted to know how you got to
discover all those things,
and are you doing any other
projects with any of the
subcontinent singers
or musicians?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, I would
never call Nusrat raw.
He was a master, certainly,
when we met him.
And for those of you who don't
know him, he's like Pavarotti
from Pakistan, but in Qawwali.
And it was actually Pete
Townsend from The Who that
told me about Qawwali.
I didn't really know
much about it.
When we were, in 1980, trying to
put WOMAD, this world music
festival, together, he said,
you should check that out.
And the first group we
had in was a group
called Sabri Brothers.
And they were great, but they
introduced us to others.
And Nusrat was the
most revered.
And we put him with
Massive Attack.
There's one little byline here,
but we had a thing where
we deliberately excluded the
artists' own country or
geographical region from our
record contract, because very
often, artists would survive
selling their records with
their own cassette tapes.
When Massive Attack did "Mustt
Mustt" with Nusrat, I think it
was the biggest single in India
or the subcontinent.
And of course, we didn't benefit
from that at all,
which did make us think,
scratch our heads.
But he was such an amazing
artist to work with, I think
probably the finest singer I've
ever worked with, in that
he not only had this
passionate voice,
but he could improvise.
And it was like composition on
the spot in an extraordinarily
powerful way.
So yeah.
With WOMAD, we have a lot of
artists from the subcontinent,
and I think we'll still
continue doing that.
I'm not sure what there
is right now.
INTERVIEWER: I think we've got
time for one more question.
PETER GABRIEL: I'm happy to
do two, as we've got two.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I guess my anecdote of
superfanhood is my LPs in my
bag here that I retain, two of
which are both your works.
Every other one I've
gotten rid of.
And I've had them since
I was a kid.
I was at your '86 show.
And I'm here to express my
gratitude for your grace and
humanity with how you've used
your celebrity status over the
years, and for the decades of
positive introspection that
your poetry has helped
me with.
So thank you for being here.
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: It seems like after
that question, we should
probably just close it.
But since you're here and you've
been so gracious, I was
wondering if you could talk
about "In Your Eyes" and what
that song means,
and writing it.
It's one of my favorite
songs, but I'd like to
hear more about it.
PETER GABRIEL: Well, I guess
it was a love song.
But what I was interested in,
too, was I had a place in
Senegal for a while, and I was
fascinated that in Africa you
could have love songs that could
be interpreted two ways.
So it could be human physical
love, or it could be spiritual
love for God.
And in my world, the church
thing and the physical,
romantic thing were
miles apart.
So that was a starting point
for trying to sort of
integrate some of the
lyrical ideas.
And then I think it was
immortalized when John Cusack
held up the boombox, which was
later, I think, repeated with
"Shock the Monkey,"
playing on--
now here's, I'm going to--
"South Park," thank you.
If I can travel as a
group, then we can
share bits of my memory.
AUDIENCE: Well, great,
thank you very much.
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
And I was going to talk about
Youssou, too, because I think
he's this sort of divine
intervention at the end.
Because his voice is just
straight out of heaven.
AUDIENCE: So really, then,
it's about both?
It's about love of a
person and of God.
PETER GABRIEL: Yeah.
I think it's just--
yeah.
Just outpouring of love.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Well, thank you.
Thanks a lot for coming.
PETER GABRIEL: Sure.
Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: And I guess the
final question is, you're
going to be taking, at the end
of the concert tour, a year.
And then do you have anything
that you can reveal, as far as
plans beyond that
or what's next?
PETER GABRIEL: Well, there still
is this quite a lot of
stuff in the writing can, and
there are a few projects that
I think I'll get back to
work in September.
So I guess we'll
know more then.
We're trying to get--
there's a thing called
Gabble, which is
sort of like a visual--
we're trying to do a visual
language for the net where it
turns words into pictures.
And we're just starting
with that.
And I'm sure I'll be hustling
for help later
on, so don't worry.
INTERVIEWER: Have a wonderful
show tonight.
Have a great rest of the tour
and a great sabbatical.
And thanks so much for
coming by Google.
PETER GABRIEL: Thanks.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]